ming ching chao is caught in the web of
a massive u.s program targeting spies
for china but he's not on trial for
spying the justice department has
charged the southern illinois university
mathematics professor with financial
fraud and tax evasion for allegedly
failing to disclose grants from chinese
universities when he applied for a grant
from the u.s national science foundation
critics say that's the problem with the
china initiative if authorities can't
prove spying they'll look for something
anything else
i feel it's
completely xenophobic it's racist
cara benyas a friend who set up a
gofundme page says the trump era spy
catching program aimed at preventing
china from stealing intellectual
property is not catching spies they're
going about it in a completely wrong way
i mean they are clearly targeting for
the most part
asian americans and
you know we've seen this in past
instances in history
and it's happening now when the biden
administration inherited the china
initiative it decided that wasn't the
right approach it replaced that with a
broader plan called the strategy for
countering nation-state threats
targeting espionage from china russia
iran and north korea since then there
have been trials across the u.s with at
best a mixed record of convictions
the case of gang chan a massachusetts
institute of technology professor
accused of lying about his ties to china
was dismissed without trial university
of kansas professor feng franklin tao
was convicted in april of fraud and
making false statements but the judge
has declined to set a sentencing date
and is considering defense claims that
there are major problems with the
prosecution's case fbi officials point
to the case of harvard university
chemist charles lieber convicted of
lying to federal agencies about his tie
to a chinese talent recruitment program
failing to disclose a chinese bank
account and tax evasion they say there's
good reason to focus on china
there is no country no country that
presents a broader
more severe threat to our innovation our
ideas on our economic security than
china does
joyce zhao a chinese student living in
chicago says the focus on china makes
the u.s an increasingly hostile
environment there's this huge rise of
anti-asian violence and discrimination
many smaller incidents as well and i do
think that
this these trials
are originated from these similar social
political factors
the case of ming ching chao marks the
latest test of whether the anti-spying
program will survive public scrutiny
john hendren al jazeera chicago